camila kate told me that you and her and
sean watched the movie together
and he said but wait wait wait i'm her
real prince
that's so funny
yeah we did um
um okay was on zoom and it was like the
first time
the movie and sean was there and it was
just so funny what makes him your real
prince
my guy i love that guy i mean i was a
little bit like he he could have played
the role truly in case that he's too
tall though
[Laughter]
yeah he's pretty tall but yeah i would
have been weird because you know he's my
boyfriend irl
but um yeah it was fun has it been cool
to have him support you and to share
this journey with him because you guys
went through it with this movie pausing
for covet and all that has it been fun
to have sean cheering you on as your
real life prince totally i mean he's uh
you know he's the best and i think we're
really supportive of each other and you
know always want to see each other like
didn't he surprise you for your birthday
yeah he did he surprised me about the
week of the ball and he saw me do one of
those things yeah he saw me do the scene
with the gong like where i fall or
whatever oh yeah um yeah and so yeah he
was he was he was there for the whole
beginning of it and uh was so supportive
and uh yeah i'm i'm lucky i have awesome
people in my life
i am your fabulous godmother do you want
to go to that ball and meet a bunch of
rich people who will change your life
yes i was just crying and singing about
it like two minutes ago camila your
first lead role in a movie and it's
cinderella how did it feel for you to
get this part and how did you want to
make her different well i think kate can
in writing it made her different i i
feel like i was just really inspired by
the character and really inspired by the
film and i feel like it just like
really turned around the kind of you
know like cinderella that's like
patiently like sitting in the room and
like you know lying for the prince and
sad and scared and you know obviously
like this character has moments of doubt
and sadness too but i think it's like
much more
rounded and she's also you know angry at
this world that and the society that's
not really letting her be like a whole
person
yeah she just is following her instincts
on changing that for herself and i just
think that's really brave and
we should all be so brave
she's gonna inspire a whole new
generation of kids which is amazing you
get to sing all these iconic songs i
mean janet jackson and madonna and jlo
how did you feel taking on those iconic
songs and have either of you spoken to
any of those incredible artists about
doing the songs for the movie i wish i
would
definitely
you're amazing you did you did tell
jayla i was like i think i told jayla
did you just do you have her own text i
do have her own voice that is so cool
it's pretty sick and i think i've
voicemained her and i was like hey in
our in the movie
that i just did we had let's get loud on
your song i don't remember what she said
i don't even remember if i texted her
that but i wanted to check it out but i
think i texted her madonna did not call
me but i mean i'm sure she thinks i'm
wonderful in the movie and
um but we had so much fun it's greed
it's it's so great we had a great
arrangers um and now they kind of you
know redid these these songs to
modernize them but it's it's just so
much fun the
seeing the juxtaposition of them and and
and what we've heard and then back in
this
time period whatever it is and getting
to play with all that and see how it
tells the story differently and unfolds
up here
adina i think you said something like
one of your greatest roles ever you've
played these great parts but one of them
is motherhood which i thought was so
beautiful has your son seen the movie
yet and or if not how excited are you to
show it to him yeah i'm excited he's
gonna come uh monday to the premiere he
usually gets really he's you know
embarrassed of me and many other times
in his life but when there are moments
like this he holds my hand and i can
sense he's very proud of me that's sweet
oh that's incredible um you guys you're
both so great camila you're so funny in
this movie i loved seeing your comedic
timing was it fun for you to like
embrace that awkward side you're kind of
doing it on tick tock too now which is
great i have one thing to say
you better work [ __ ]
[Music]
i love a tick tock moment
yeah it was really fun and obviously you
know uh kaye
has so much experience in
comedic writing and i learned so much
like in the process and mostly just
learned like you know she would always
say like jokes and songs jokes and songs
whenever
you know just to remind us that it's
really just like
being stupid and singing
you